عدد سكان الارض خطى 8 مليارات فهل هي فرصه
للاحتفال ام للفزع بالنسبه للامين العام
للامم المتحده انطونيو غوتيرس هذه العتبه
تستحق الاحتفال لانها ترمز للتنوع وايضا
التطور ذكر العالم
بمسؤوليته المشتركه تجاه الكوكب وعلى نفس
النمط الايجابي ارجعت الامم المتحده النمو
السكاني الى تطور البشريه اذا ان الناس
باتو يعمرون اكثر بفضل تحسن خدمات الصحه
العامه والتغذيه والنظافه الشخصيه
والادويه لكن من جهه اخرى فاقما النمو
السكناني التداعيات البيئيه الذي يقول
الخبراء ان نمو السكانيه السريع يقللوا من
جوده وكميميه الموارد الطبيعيه من خلال
الزراعه المكثفه وتجزئه الاراضي وكذلك
لاستغلال والاستهلاك المفرط للمواد خاصه
من قبل الاشخاص الاكثر ثراءا ياتي ذلك في
الوقت الذي حذرت فيه منظمه الاغذيه
والزراعه التابعه مع المتحده الفاو من اثر
هذه الزياده السكانيه على فجوه الامن
الغذائيه قالت المنظمه ان تكاليف واردات
الغذاء في انحاء العالم تتجه صوبات تسجيل
ما يقرب من اثنين تريليون دولار في 20 22
مايو فاقم الضغط على البلدان الاكثر فقرا
والتي شحت على الارجح كميات الغذاء فيها
وهي اقل بكثير